heidi ho rejectos we're gonna watch
ourselves a special halloween episode
which i'm feeling cocky today that's
right we're gonna watch brooklyn nine
nine two by three four four four
halloween two
just after halloween kills has come out
halloween right around the corner this
would have been perfect if we landed
this on halloween date nah hit that like
button subscribe click that bell check
us out on patreon blah blah blah thanks
you too priper
hey yeah
every halloween i dress up in an amazing
costume and you never get what i am no
we get what you are an adult man who
enjoys dress-up very funny rosette this
year
that won't be a problem because you're
going to pick my costume
ms pac-man's nipple no that's brown
to be on not to be not to be thank you
joan of arc two woke he-man master of
the universe yeah i got it gay robin
hood
that's what it is
it's halloween all right and what
happened last halloween oh i listened to
the cd i bought the night before the
franz blueheim birthday concert please
stop
[Laughter]
you bet me that you could steal my medal
of valor and you did consequently i was
forced to do your paperwork for a week
and to say words i thought i'd never
have to say jake peralta is an amazing
detective
genius
that's mouthing along steal the watch
right off your wrist
or we could just not do it at all this
year come on homie
it's not worth all the trouble just so
you might call me an amazing captain
slash genius and give me one week of
overtime for free all right fine i'll
double the overtime i'll triple it i'll
quadruple it i will 5-drupal and i'll
5-drupal the overtime oh oh no
if you steal my watch by midnight i will
do your paperwork for a week but if you
fail you will give me five weeks of
overtime for free correct
so we have reached an accord accord
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's with the tux i decided to class
up this year's event i bought it off a
disgraced magician and it is chock full
of scarves
what how a real magician never tells
young man
i've all been given a specific role and
a code name rosa you're the dagger sarge
the hammer amy the hall monitor yeah
sucky william hitchcock i'm just gonna
call you your real name so you don't get
confused smart what
[Laughter]
i remember this guy probably because
you've arrested him twice for
pickpocketing we will all work together
as a team to move the captain into
position fingers loving that code name
will remove the captain's watch and
replace it with replica watch oh that is
a very dead dove
if he's been arrested before how do you
know he's any good perhaps this will
answer your question
fingers
you knew it
but where's the smoked turkey check your
breast pocket
i've decided to bring the opera
to you
hitchcock scully
[Music]
it's hammer time
you're up jagger
no need for the somersault disagree
yeah
it's time to
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
ow
let me help you up
on behalf of the nine-nine
dude
thank you sir
if you need anything jeez please contact
me
the replica is on the wrist oh he knows
he's got to he knows the spirit of a
friendly bet but this all went too far
am i understood completely understood
sir i'm sorry not as sorry as you're
going to be at midnight when you realize
you've lost
everything
yeah he's totally lost
peralta's lost man named mccreery left a
package for me yeah it's here you sir oh
no did he run off with it he must have
that's weird just a
note thanks for the watch oh no
mccreery stole the captain's watch
breaking news there's been a terrible
development not now charles oh
good call media blackout
better be a good phone case can we
please press pause on this bed for 10
minutes sure or we could press fast
forward and i could watch you talk like
a chipmunk peralta i'm doing the support
of you
kevin is bringing dinner for me and i
don't think he'd appreciate this bet we
made this watch was given to me by his
father just before he died oh
a death watch cool please never call it
that
finger's just texted he said he wants to
meet up yes let's get out of here be
cool holt's watching pretend i just said
something really funny
[Laughter]
my dance troupe floorgasm is performing
tonight in the booty shake grand prix
[Laughter]
we go in hard and tough
and take what's rightfully ours i want
three hundred dollars absolutely no
problem whatever you need
take my shoes can i please have the
watch now you already have it you had it
all along what what are you talking
about i put in the glove compartment of
your car i didn't want to walk around
with a stolen police captain's watch not
an idiot
i would say thank you but even for a
criminal your customer service has been
abysmal my pleasure someone's stealing
their card you should confirm that i
think to win this bet someone's
oh syringe you got to think of a way to
catch them with that truck
oh how about this
yes hop in
jackass charles how come you're so much
slower than a car
well i'm just trying not to joss you too
much you're the champagne of friends
champagne of friends
i was gonna wear this jacket to my
cousin's butt mitzvah next week
[Music]
i won't stop the party but i do need the
bus
it's halloween
[Music]
halloween
orgasm just came by and danced me out of
the group
oh no
and while i generally nail everything
i'm just having trouble balancing my
studies and my passion for dance plus
you're working full-time yeah that
actually doesn't factor into it
whatsoever
of course
the world just lost an angel
you know what
i'm gonna dance with you tonight
no terry crews dancing
nypd you guys towed my car and i really
need it back mm-hmm
you got a badge uh yeah i sure do oh
man
demons on the party bus must have stolen
it if you got a license and credit card
just pay to get it out i don't have my
id or my credit cards but i really need
that car please i'm begging you rule the
rules i can't do nothing for you
i'm just gonna give up on this and head
straight home without trying anything
else
oh no
look at the view from up here
i didn't know we lived near water
[Music]
wire i can still win this bet
i can still win
oh god
[Laughter]
oh my god
there is a tiny chance i may not win
this bet
criminal i hired to lift your watch was
not trustworthy and subsequently losing
your death watch my watch is right here
no
i made a switch that's a fake no
this one's a fake
[Music]
you played me
like france blueheim
[Laughter]
when i did no paperwork i started to
plot my red bed
during the year i drew your attention to
my watch
you're eight minutes late
you're 14 minutes late
scumbag pickpocket is dan mccreary he
can take anything off of anyone
anything
anyone
[Laughter]
so size
mccreary stole my watch and then
replaced it with a replica and while you
celebrated mccreary put my watch back in
my pocket the watch never left my person
while you met with mccreery santiago
placed a fire oh no
oh
he had a badge and a gun and he would do
anything to help you enter a parade of
drunks that separated the two a voice
sounded familiar who was it
then two bears spilled their drinks what
is the hitchcock and scully those babies
scully yeah
one of them sounded familiar you didn't
look like a cop but you still had your
badge that is until you entered
the party bus
rosa's feline
throw your badge on
halloween
you in the mask you sly son of a [ __ ]
oh no
did they really smash my car no in fact
i had them wash it good one captain you
can't wash a car
[Laughter]
captain raymond holt you are an amazing
police captain slash
genius
[Applause]
[Music]
i started planning next year's heist
just this minute good
then you're only three months behind
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn you floorgasm
now get your game face on sarge it's
time to dance if you forget your moves
just rip your cape off and throw me up
in the air like a pizza
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do they win they're gonna win i hope so
too they have to win i hope they won all
right john was that your favorite
halloween episode it's my favorite
halloween
anything ever no movie comes close no
life experience just this episode
i got you one of those watches to time
your yes hands
here have mine
it's an analog watch
with a second hand
[Laughter]
just don't steal it from me because i
don't know if they make them anymore
every time i'm like do i team up
ah it's worth a shot don't team up
nah we're not on live stage my response
it works a lot better over just on live
stage
does it
well
i mean we could phone some people and
ask
[Laughter]
instead all the pens yeah
but yes this was a highly
enjoyable halloween and even though you
gotta imagine that on the second time
around holt will not be fooled so easily
this was just such a blast to watch
unfold
yeah it does a really good job at like
it
you me it's like this because of the
fact that the swap happens so early and
you know there's going to be a twist
reveal coming that you're like okay i
don't know what it is but holt obviously
is gonna win this one
but then it does have you side tracking
because it gets you caught up in oh
maybe it's not a twist reveal that holt
has something planned
but the fact that he fails and loses the
watch in some way yeah um because of
like the thief getting away with it like
that had me hooked into it to the point
where i was like oh this is all going
wrong and you're so engrossed in what's
happening there they're like oh so you
might just fail naturally because of
what went wrong with trusting a criminal
for a game
so that was really clever especially
because like when holt comes in and he's
like pissed off at him at the
interrogation room
uh but who was the flute guy oh i
couldn't like i don't know the the name
that's so funny
like a flute at the end that's
such a great call yeah
absolutely this one was full of that
stuff and i mean
andre brower like top notch in this
episode like some of those like the way
he mixes that deadpan with broad comedy
is very funny well the way how he um i i
love like
how this season alone in the past four
episodes shows you his real competitive
side yeah
where he's willing to get dirty to to
get the the lead up on someone i find
that very amusing
uh yeah this is a really funny ass
episode the gina stuff was kind of all
right that was whatever she's going to
college and doing some stuff for herself
still sometimes feels like it's a little
trite like you're trying to come up with
stuff for gina to do it wasn't like
terrible it's still amusing i wish we
got to see more of the dance i wish they
had done a full-on like dance sequence
at the end yeah and that would have been
more uh rewarding for that moment yeah i
think so if it had really built to that
and then everybody was there for like
they are it happens but yeah not as like
a centerpiece it's more just like the
button at the end yeah where like the
dance off is supposed to be uh like uh
the ending joke for the episode
i'm surprised everyone's turning against
jake except for
except for boyle always loyal always
loyal boyle that's right that's why they
call them that and yeah i
i thought it was great how they all
worked against jake they all worked with
him and they were all double agents
against him at the same time yeah so he
can't trust anyone so next halloween he
has to do is on his own yeah and he's
going to be planning it from this moment
forward
which i love that too about the whole
like i planted the watch in your
subconscious mind
over and over again to dictate the rules
of the game
yeah
it's very busy even though it's not you
know like a mystery you could unravel
for yourself i still
who felt like oh you could just throw
the saw music over this right now and i
would be giggling a glee
the twist reveals are so well done yeah
this one and the last one just so so
excellently uh constructed i do
i do kind of
when you do like pickpocket stuff i
really like when you could re-watch and
see how they did it
like oh it did happen in this moment
that's and it's a comedy show and it was
so absurd like with the whole like
turkey or something and in boyle's
breast pocket like so obviously it's
unrealistic and there's another point of
that it's large that's larger than life
it's not supposed to be realistic
because i was watching there's no way
you grabbed any of that yeah yeah like
if i rewatched it like there's no way oh
yeah and i feel like that's part of
almost the gag of that scene because you
know having the contrast with the later
moment where they actually show you like
all the inserts of him taking the watch
and putting it back on yeah he just
walks in doesn't get anywhere near
anyone's hips and has everyone's wallet
i would love to know how to pickpocket
someone well you could probably find
like a youtube video about it or
skillshare class but the question is
was there ever
was there ever
a
watch inside
of his car of his glove box we never
found out we never found out we never
found out todd todd you should know we
don't know the truth buddy todd what's
the truth bud
we don't know the truth
oh
cuddles are temporary
before he wriggles out of your grass
[Laughter]
all right guys well yeah that was a fun
one man that was a fun one always a
blast can't wait for next halloween
in like brooklyn nine-nine kills yeah
and then it's just a mob mentality
movie about the precinct it'll be like
assault on precinct 13.
all right guys well thank you for being
here hit that like button subscribe
click the notification bell last but not
least
sarah campbell
it's halloween time and you know what i
can see you dressing up as
a sexy
sexy ass elephant oh yeah totally a big
ass elephant costume yeah or a giraffe
or something yeah why change the bit
why change
why
why why
why change elephants i don't understand
i'll leave this shout out okay first the
long ass yes and then then the changing
and i don't understand
your improv these days john
gonna go take a class no go with it go
with the giraffe thing go go syracuse
because
yeah the the giraffes are like the
funniest and and you know funnest anime
you were looking to me just go for it
just dress like an elephant all right
there are probably way more options in
terms of costumes you got like dumbo
elephant you could have like a circus
elephant which is also kind of a dumbo
elephant uh you know plus you get the
trunk in the ear attachments this is so
much potential for more costume items to
wear plus gray a lot easier to bound in
if you want to just do like i'm not
quite like the full-on animal accurate
elephant i'm just kind of elephant style
clothing
you know wow so
this is what i had planned for my hair
this elephant bit was going to be way
funnier about all the pranks and tricks
no no pranks feed you pools and it's
fine no clearly uh it's really crazy
it's an elephant trick it's okay it's
okay she doesn't get here now instead
all you did was describe features of an
elephant
and that was the costume
very creative
[Music]